[Music]
according to one theory mayonnaise
originated in the town of mahon in spain
where it was known as salsa mejanessa
mayonnaise makes sandwiches zestier
turns canned tuna into tuna salad
hard-boiled eggs into egg salad and is a
creamy dip for french fries belgian
style
[Music]
mayonnaise recipes vary but all have
eggs and oil as the main ingredients
the eggs can be all yolks all whites or
a combination of both
at this mayonnaise factory the raw eggs
arrive in liquid form by tanker truck
they've been pasteurized to kill off
salmonella and other common bacteria
the egg supplier has also cleaned and
sealed the tank valve an additional food
safety precaution
a worker clamps a sanitary evacuation
hose to the tank then with a few blows
of a mallet releases the valve
a pump draws the eggs through the hose
into a refrigerated receiving tank
the second main ingredient soybean oil
arrives by a railway tanker car
like all bulk ingredient deliveries for
food safety the tank is sealed at the
supplier to ensure it isn't open prior
to arrival here
a pumping system transfers the oil to a
large holding tank
meanwhile factory workers weigh out the
ingredients that make up this company's
secret blend of spices
next they mix this spice blend with
white vinegar cider vinegar and salt
then they add liquid natural flavors
[Music]
they pour this mixture into a large tank
of room temperature water producing what
they call a slurry
[Music]
the raw eggs meanwhile have been
transferred into a large refrigerated
holding tank
so now there are three holding tanks at
the ready a slurry tank an egg tank and
an oil tank
a computerized proportioning system
extracts the required amount from each
tank and sends it to a mixing vessel
a couple of minutes of mixing at high
agitation merges the eggs oil and slurry
into tangy creamy mayonnaise
[Music]
the factory draws samples periodically
and sends them to its quality control
department for analysis
the lab technicians there evaluate
several criteria such as color
consistency and of course flavor
in this test for example they mix the
mayo with phenolphthalein a ph level
indicator and deionized water to check
the acidity level
once the mayonnaise passes quality
control inspection this rotary filler
dispenses it into recyclable
polyethylene jars
it fills each jar in just a quarter
second
[Music]
the next machine twists on a plastic cap
[Music]
inside the cap is a foil seal
this machine uses targeted induction
heat to fuse the seal to the rim of the
jar without heating the mayonnaise in
the process
the seal preserves freshness and
indicates the jar wasn't tampered with
after leaving the factory
the labeling machine glues on one end of
the label spins the jar to wrap the
label around then glues down the other
end
[Music]
the quality control lab also performs
some post-production spot checks
in this test technicians use a machine
called a viscometer to measure their
product's consistency
the factory also packages its mayo into
single serving pouches they're made of
polyethylene film on one side foil
printed with the product label on the
other
this multitasking machine forms rows of
pouches inserts about four ounces of
mayonnaise per pouch then seals and
separates the pouches
[Music]
these pouches are shipped to ready-made
sandwich vendors and fast food
restaurants whose customers need mayo on
the go
[Music]
you